et pêcheurs tout le monde le sait qu'on
sait devoir authentique c'est qu'il ya
forcément dangers qui guettent les
marins pêcheurs n'ont pas attendu les
consignes de la mairie pour s'occuper de
leur outil de travail
karti les abîment les amis les proches
mettre la main à la pâte
après avoir plié les filets de pêche
c'est au rythme des bois glissé que les
yoles une elles sont ramenées à leurs
abris cautionner la prévention est une
règle ici a pris tout son sens depuis
les épisodes successifs de vaduz
quand il s'agit de personnes vulnérables
a prédit c'est d'ailleurs toute l'équipe
municipale qui s'y colle
danlos - en cas d'évacuation
on arrive à se débrouiller quand même on
a la voiture de la commune et à des gens
qui nous aident à les mettre dans la
voiture et
amener au point de rassemblement une
trentaine de personnes âgées ou
invalides doivent être prévenues ou
évacuées avant le passage d'isaac
en attendant que leur soit communiquée
l'adresse des refuges de la commune
l'ensemble de la population s'inquiète
akiba la grille volet nous et qui dégage
c'est la sécurité
jouer en mairie où se sont réunis ce
matin les principaux référents de crise
on mesure les risques liés à la fois la
houle cyclonique et à la descente
dollars s'il y a que le risque l'art
nous avions déjà des lieux bien prévu
pour comme seul refuge
mais s'il a second set ce risque là
s'ajoutent risque de houle cyclonique
effectivement nous ne pouvons pas garder
ses
ces zones refuges l'église catholique
saint joseph le temple adventiste et la
salle félix crowley sont les refuges vos
tenues en cas d'évacuation
aujourd'hui le temps était si clément
qu'il laissait entrevoir les contours de
l'île voisine la dominique
un tableau qui dans les prochaines 24
heures s'effacera avec le temps